today we are looking at some of the
worst crowdfunding projects in the world
starting with this one the leaf mask it
raised over four million dollars and
claimed to be an n99 mask that's four
levels better than the n95 but people
got skeptical when their hepa filters
weren't actually space-age tech at all
if you look really closely there's a
little diamond pattern on it just like
toilet paper
that's not a safety filter
yikes you thought you were getting in 99
ply and it was one play people were so
mad about this that they started to try
to track down the creator of this scam
and um when they finally confronted him
he
he gave him the oldest line in the book
how come you haven't contacted me i came
by your house i wanted to ask you some
questions i'm just heading to the
airport uh you can reach out to me where
where are you headed airport the airport
what are you going to the airport for
um i think i can answer that question
i think he suddenly got a need to go
international is my guess all right i
know it's ridiculous but it's gonna get
worse next scam ladies and gentlemen do
you remember this guys this is the uno
brush raised 1.6 million dollars it's a
toothbrush for every part of your mouth
all at once sounds great right what
could go wrong with a stylish danish
mouth gag well it turns out a lot
they've actually
gone under yes they've declared
bankruptcy in a statement that talks a
lot about unforeseen challenges they
basically say hey your money's gone and
everybody who hasn't gotten the product
isn't gonna get it and just like that
they made a clean mistake
done
dumb joke sorry for the dumb jokes guys
there's going to be a lot of them now
before we go into our next scam i want
to remind you don't forget ladies and
gentlemen what month it is it's a coffee
sill of christmas which means it's time
to pump the stock it's absolutely free
just like and subscribe and if we get to
1 million subs by the end of the month
we are giving 10 000
to save the children's the actual
charity thank you for all your support
now back to the video guys this next one
actually we have some good news about
this is a story of crowdfunding scammers
finally getting caught arrested and
sentenced to eight years in prison
that's right you thought it was harmless
to promise everything and deliver
nothing but the guy behind the dragonfly
future phone finally found justice if
you don't remember this flaming dumpster
fire this was a hugely successful
campaign that raised 5.7 million dollars
so that everyone could get all their
smart devices in one let's watch the
promotional video and you tell me when
you think this is full of it introducing
the dragonfly by folding and
transforming dragonfly provides the
devices you already use in an elegant
new form creating one device out of
three to truly simplify your life with
its dual displays everything from
working playing and communicating
becomes a breeze well you can't do that
flip it around the he's a transformer
guys i mean honestly who fell for this
5.7 million dollars to fund some unknown
company that came out of nowhere that
promised you the impossible on indiegogo
just
take my money i guess but eventually i
guess people found justice because after
over half a decade the creator has now
been sentenced to eight years in prison
and bear in mind eight years might seem
like a long time but that's only a
little longer than his backers had to
wait without receiving a product now the
last few products we're going to be
reviewing on this episode of gofundme
garbage it's going to be a little
different i'm going to try to be ahead
of the curve on this one these are
products that are not scams yet but that
i predict will either under deliver
horribly or should be criminal to be
worn outside you see style is not
exactly a forte of these crowdfunding
types they're too busy imagining the
future to worry about such things as
style or being able to wear something
outside without being the laughing stock
of your neighborhood so first up to the
future we have metal detecting sandals
these are made for people whose number
one problem is wearing a metal detector
on the beach and wishing that they could
walk on metal detectors so the first
thing you're gonna do when you're out
looking for treasure is um turn on your
sandals and then you're going to
well try to walk in these things now i
want to watch watch these first steps as
you just realize what an absolute
disaster these things are
that looks so uncomfortable and just try
to imagine holding a conversation on the
beach and your shoes are beeping at you
and it's like oh hold on real quick i
gotta turn off my shoes
oh and of course since they're electric
um you have to plug them in at night so
don't forget to plug in both of your
sandals
now if your eyes are getting tired of
looking at horrible products we may have
just the thing for you this is the idea
uh it's a personal eye massager that
looks like you're trying out for the
x-men this thing easily met its funding
goal and raised two hundred thousand
dollars
and i'm sure you'll see why in a second
hmm
[Music]
did that say truly wearable these have
to be the least wearable things i've
ever seen i mean imagine putting these
on anywhere and they don't even look
that comfortable to wear look at her
eyes that this does not look like
not look like you're having a good time
[Music]
no
oh dude it's great marketing great i
gotta hand it to him it looks like great
marketing but you honestly look like
you're in a d-list marvel movie
now last but not least might feel like a
rerun to you this is a product called
dmask and if it looks similar to the
leaf mask it is similar but only with
one difference this product might kill
you here's the creator
taking off this very form-fitting mask
here and here's him walking around his
neighborhood like a totally normal not
at all a super villain guy it doesn't
matter who we are what matters is our
plan now why did i say it might kill you
well very simple reason you see these
two hoses right here in the back well
these are the only ways to get oxygen
and carbon dioxide in and out of the
mask and since they have these long
tubes you have to force a ton of air out
of your mouth to clear the tubes and
then you have to suck a lot of air back
in to actually get fresh oxygen into
your lungs and all of it goes through
these tiny pinholes so um yeah hopefully
your thing doesn't actually get
suctioned on your face because um you
could very easily suffocate yourself
in this stylish mask
literally just think about it most masks
you're having air
and carbon dioxide exchanged all
throughout the mass this one you have
two tiny tubes that are your only
lifeline just just imagine trying to
suck a long tube and it's got a bunch of
tiny holes at the end trying to breathe
through that it it's a travesty luckily
for the founder um the mask probably
will never make a full seal and it was
never funded so this is very unlikely to
hurt somebody but the level of stupidity
on these websites is truly remarkable so
anyways i feel like we've gone through
the full circle of people going to jail
people who should go to jail
and people outright scamming people um
that's basically it
this is your money at work guys
gofundme is where your dreams go to die
thanks for watching i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]